st-pierre 4 heures du matin dans la rue
de la cayenne une silhouette s'avance
mais ça va auchan mais taper konaté
à l'heure où la plupart des gens dorment
encore daniel prend la route pour aller
dans les champs de canne à sucre y les
coupeurs de canne mon réveil sonne à 3m
santé la cadence et lui alors
ok
après plusieurs kilomètres à travers
routes et sentiers le saint-pierrois
arrive sur son lieu de travail et se
prépare l'accoutrement est simple et
modeste à l'image des premiers cooper de
la réunion nous ne se saquer et les
trouver sur venez ça les confidences ont
acheté un paquet d
ce set c'est le métier de coupeurs de
cannes est apparu à la réunion dès le
début du peuplement à partir de 763 la
can était alors utilisé pour faire de la
raque ou du flan gourin les deux nom
désignant le rhum clandestins de
bourbourg c'est un métier réputé très
dur le coupeur passe la journée plié en
deux jusqu'au ras du sol pour sectionner
les plantes à leur base à l'aide d'un
sabre puis redresser pour supprimer les
feuilles superficiel et pouvant mais je
suis à voir à la volonté le courage et
châteaux au matin pour atténuer la
pénibilité du travail
les coupeurs se lève très tôt le matin
pour éviter les grosses chaleurs de la
mi journée
surtout que dans ce métier les shorts
sont quasi proscrit par ce qu il fait
tellement chaud et adebayor mais on sort
de les propager pas que ça
dans un autre champ du sud thierry a lui
aussi commencé très tôt sa journée de
coupe c'est avec une lampe frontale
qu'il commence à travailler
un travail qu'il a appris dès sa tendre
jeunesse des pieds petit mon papa était
front des chars est donc toujours dans
la cale et sont réveillés à 3 heures et
à quatre pattes est dans le champ ben
nous marier hier c'est les a4 et entre
veille parce qu'elle avait des
bouilloires fait occuper animaux tient
lui ni pour les arabes
après le transport de tous avant
l'économie est maintenant bien il ya une
revanche
fait le boulot l'ena délié saper son
vivant comme idéobain me lève à des
heures du matin c'était là tout le monde
doit encore l as été estimée 8 pas
encore mal et déjà mouillé coupeurs de
canne à sucre un métier longtemps qui
n'a jamais fait rêver mais pour daniel
et thiery mieux vaut ça que de ne rien
faire le métier fait encore vivre leur
famille tu l'as manqué le cicc est à la
base un niveau mais fait notamment de
halle et la boutique
personnellement je pense que la calomnie
à à disparaître
c'est pas notre faute